how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and mcu and
yesterday a lot of news released the
press junket for shang chi and the
legend of the tin ring started which
means interviews are happening and a lot
of people have been interviewing marvel
studios as president kevin feige and
they've actually surprisingly been
getting a lot of information from him
some of it big some of it not so big but
regardless there is a lot to go over
today including of course spiderman nowy
home avengers 5 the next avengers movie
deadpool 3 big black panther 2 news and
when to expect some trailers of course
and if you love to stay up to date on
the mcu be sure to subscribe so you
don't miss out on any of the latest
videos
before we get started however big thank
you to skillshare for sponsoring this
video skillshare is an online learning
community that offers thousands of
classes for creative people and i think
everybody knows by now i'm a pretty avid
skillshare user i've used skillshare to
take classes about youtube about
photoshop about final cut pro and other
editing software and if you're looking
to do youtube yourself it's a great
place to learn everything you need to
know i also use it personally i used to
use it to learn how to play guitar
better and now i'm using it to try and
learn how to sing better if you are
looking for a place to explore your
creativity or to simply get better at
things skillshare is the perfect place
to learn all of these things and the
great news is is the first thousand of
my subscribers to click the link in the
description will get a one month free
trial of skillshare so you can start
exploring your creativity today just
click the link in the description down
below to get started
so first things first i know everybody
wants to know about spiderman no way
home and some of you may have heard this
but kevin feige did indeed confirm we
will be getting a trailer before the
movie comes out now of course this isn't
breaking news but some people were
actually starting to believe that
perhaps they weren't actually going to
release a trailer the marketing strategy
for spider-man no way home has been a
little bit different than we've seen for
pretty much anything in the past but i
do believe that this is due to the fact
that it's going to be an insanely huge
film and right now they're not exactly
sure if they're going to keep that
release date as of right now it's the
same and hopefully it stays that way but
i did actually happen to hear some news
recently about footage at cinemacon on
monday according to a personal source of
mine sony does indeed have something
prepared for spiderman home for
cinemacon it was not classified whether
or not this is a trailer or footage he
simply said something is prepared now
will the public see that right away
probably not we're probably not going to
see that monday maybe tuesday but that
is not confirmed it's just a guess at
this point in time however like i've
been saying we're gonna get a
description of whatever is shown no it
probably won't be leaked and if it does
sony is definitely going to be copy
striking people and perhaps even taking
legal action but one thing you can't
really do that for is a description and
people are gonna come out of that
cinemacon footage trailer whatever
they're showing and they're gonna talk
and the second i hear anything about it
i'll be sure to do a video on it asap
and you can also notice that some of the
official sony youtube channels have made
a playlist now for spider-man no way
home and the current thing and the only
thing that's in the playlist is the
title reveal but the playlist is made
which means other videos for no way home
are coming this is another good sign
that the trailer or footage or whatever
is not too far away and they're going to
upload it on youtube so i think we're
getting pretty close and we're just a
few days away from getting a description
now we do have some avengers 5 news from
kevin feige himself in an interview that
he did with collider the mcu is a lot
bigger than it was back in 2012 and the
notion that you can now bring everybody
together will take a lot more than four
years so after stating this collider
steven weintraub asked marvel studios
president about when the next team-up
film avengers 5 could be in which kevin
feige said this i think we want there to
be a reasonable amount of time from the
end game to start a new saga which is
already underway and already started and
then you need time as you did in phase
one to build that saga before you start
bringing everyone together now clearly
things are different now before in the
first phase there were only five movies
released before avengers came out and
right now we technically only have one
movie that has been released that will
actually go into avengers 5 because
unfortunately black widow won't so right
now we just have chang chi of course the
disney plush shows will tie into the
avengers but not everybody is going to
be a part of the new avengers team so
although kevin feige does say that it's
underway and groundwork is being laid
it'll probably be another four to five
years until we get a new avengers team
at the most at least perhaps we could
get it a little bit before but we'll
probably need another four to five
movies about people who are actually
going to be a part of the new avengers
team because not everybody is but it is
actually good that marvel is taking
their time with this we don't want
things to get repetitive marvel just
can't repeat what they did for the
infinity saga they need to do something
new and when everybody sees shang chi
and i believe the eternals i think we'll
realize that marvel really is changing
up things in a very very good way so yes
the avengers team are kind of starting
to be assembled we're starting to get
introduced to them but they're not going
to come together for a few years at
least and we'll get deadpool 3 before we
get avengers 5 which to me is great news
because i really hope deadpool is a part
of the next avengers team i think it
would be hilarious and we have news on
deadpool 3 today coming from
brandondavis comicbook.com in an
interview with kevin feige brandon davis
asked him if they have a release date
window set for deadpool 3 to make his
mcu debut and kevin feige said this we
do and the script is in the works and
ryan is working very hard on it with our
writers as we speak so this is extremely
good news and i actually kind of heard
something at the premiere of xiang chi
nothing major but i did pretty much hear
that ryan reynolds right now is pretty
much just devoting all of his time to
writing the script he's pretty much just
taking his kids to school writing the
script picking them up writing the
script some more and this is great
because recently he stated that there's
about a 70 chance that they're going to
start filming in 2022 which means we'll
probably get the movie late 2022 or
early 2023 which means it's not that far
away which is awesome because i know
everybody is super excited for ryan
reynolds and deadpool to enter the
marvel cinematic universe now we have
some pretty big iron heart and black
panther 2 wakanda forever news coming
from the same interview with kevinfoggy
and comicbook.com kevin feige told
comicbook.com we're shooting black
panther wakanda forever right now and
the character of riri williams you will
meet in black panther 2 first marvel
studios has announced that dominique
thorne is going to be playing the
character of riri williams and kevin
feige said that she started shooting i
think this week before her iron heart
series so riri williams iron heart is
going to be in black panther 2 which
makes me think that perhaps her iron man
suit could be made of vibranium i think
that would be a really cool way to go
actually the biggest video i've ever
done is about a theory that iron man was
going to get a vibranium suit for
infinity war and in-game that obviously
didn't happen but i think the concept is
a really cool idea and i'm hoping that
maybe her iron heart suit will be made
of vibranium now last but not least in
an interview with collider kevin feige
did confirm that loki season 2 is
underway he stated it is underway we're
developing it as we speak the hope is
that much of the same team will return
kate is going on to bigger and better
things so the director search will begin
shortly this is great news because that
means we're not gonna have to wait years
and years for loki season two it
actually seems like it's going to be
coming relatively soon within the next
couple of years which makes a ton of
sense considering the fact that loki had
a huge huge perhaps the biggest impact
on the mcu that we've really ever seen
and we were kind of left on a
cliffhanger there so we're gonna have to
find out what happens there relatively
soon now as far as the trailer updates
aren't concerned it seems like the
rumors that we've been hearing for these
other trailers have been pretty accurate
so far yesterday we did receive the
final eternals trailer and like i said i
did hear from a source that they are
going to be showing spiderman no way
home footage at cinemacon on monday
which leads me to believe that the other
rumors i've been hearing are probably
somewhat true as well meaning that we
should be getting a hawkeye trailer this
month or next month perhaps at the emmys
a miss marvel trailer perhaps at the
same time and a doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness trailer before the
end of the year however i'm not so sure
about that doctor strange one but that's
it for all the news that happened
yesterday like i said it was a lot but
things are starting to get really really
exciting in the mcu so let me know all
of your thoughts about this in the
comments down below and how excited you
are don't forget to give the video a
like if you enjoyed it and for live
updates you can always follow me on
instagram and twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching woof
[Music]
you